[Music]  the eu response to the pandemic the  recovery and the climate crisis were  among the main topics during the 2021  state of the european union debate  between meps and the commission  president  as i look back on this past year  and if i look at the state of the union  today  i see a strong soul in everything what  we do  the ponding me alessi the profound si  catrice  notre economy social democracy  we are emerging stronger from the crisis  but this crisis has caused and left deep  social and economic wounds many people  fear for their existence for their jobs  while the economy was a big part of  mep's priorities so too was standing up  for european values  some meps were critical of the  commission president's way of working  particularly with the parliament  diplomacy  europe  and others said while the commission was  heading in the right direction towards  climate neutrality more ambitious steps  are needed  [Music]  you